I don't know that you also promote body
positivity you have a campaign a
movement called away right yeah it's a
body in neutrality right so why is this
important to you so Iowa is a body
neutrality movement it's about getting
away from thinking about your body and
instead thinking about the things in
your life that you should be grateful
for like I weigh the sum of all my parts
my way Mike you can't measure my worth
on a weighing scale you can't measure
your own like that it's insane that we
still do this to women in this day and
age so it's about like you know I weigh
my relationship my contributions to
society my financial independence my
activism that's what my way that's my
birth and so it's a movement where we
have almost a million followers and we
get 5 or 6,000 more a day of people from
everywhere from all walks of life who
are just tired of being undermined and
underestimated by society and it's this
really beautiful space that I'm
launching into a company next year and
we're gonna take this as we take this as
far as we can and we're changing laws
and changing global policies together
Wow I think sometimes we focus so much
on the aesthetics of what health looks
like instead of actual health like and
what's going on inside your body and we
just don't know you know so it's like
what's going on in someone's life so
it's I think it's a really important
thing you're doing especially because
you have such a big spotlight on you so
thank you for doing that
Thanks it's been through sympathy shame
I have no idea your furniture I
literally I'm getting trolled right now
online wild I am I
I remember you going through that and
then very shortly afterwards I gained a
lot of weight back in England I was a
radio DJ by the way you couldn't even
see me
you just had people just wanted to know
I was thinner over the airwaves
so I got nationally fat shamed for like
six months in my own country and it was
your response to yours that gave me the
strength to get through day like did I
use a word that I can't
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this